the owner of the Houston Texans is
apologizing after his comments about the
ongoing protests of NFL players during
the national anthem during a meeting
between players and owners last week Bob
McNair said if the league didn't stop
the protests and would be like quote
inmates running the prison the issue
came up when our Dana Jacobson sat down
to discuss the Atlanta Falcons new
stadium and community redevelopment plan
with owner Arthur Blank for a future
story on CBS this morning
I was there when Bob made that comment
now you know in defensive but bob is one
of the brightest fair-minded most
concerned owners in the NFL Atlanta
Falcons owner Arthur blank has called
for unity in the face of player protests
during the national anthem on Friday
blank said Texans owner Bob McNair
realized he made a poor choice of words
in saying the inmates were running the
prison given the issues and all the
sensitivities around him you know I
think others heard it differently in the
room and in responded that way but Bob
you know like most people that are
thoughtful and sensitive and caring what
she is you recognize
poor choice of words in that context let
me not defend it blank says McNair
immediately tried to smooth things over
with NFL vice president and former
player Troy Vincent after ESPN first
reported McNair's comments he issued a
written apology reading in part I used a
figure of speech that was never intended
to be taken literally
I would never characterize our players
or our league that way despite the
apology some NFL players reacted harshly
to McNair's comments at least 10 Texans
considered a walkout from practice and
protest this is the view of
clear owner relationship this is how you
view us you get a line you're an inmate
the anthem protest started last year
when then San Francisco quarterback
Colin Kaepernick refused to stand they
were brought back into the national
discussions last month when President
Trump said players who don't stand
should be fired blank says the
president's comments did not help an
already sensitive situation some you
know kerosene throw another fire from a
white building and you end up you know
with plays you know really responding to
that in a very negative way Blanc added
he understands fans anger towards
players but he doesn't think the league
should mandate players stand for the
national anthem for CBS this morning
Saturday Dana Jacobson Atlanta it is
such a sensitive situation yeah and it
is really exposed the tensions between
players and owners in a way that I think
most people were unaware of perhaps